[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild
hallo und willkommen zu einer neuen
Folge von Tatort Deutschland ich bin
Mirko Kasimir und ich bin Toni Heyer hi
zusammen Toni bei unserem heutigen Fall
kommt man aus dem Kopfschütteln nicht
raus ich wiederum bin absolut erstaunt
dass dieser Typ ernsthaft auch noch
Liebesbriefe in den Knast bekommt aber
jetzt ist erstmal Zeit dass wir ihn
vorstellen Mirko die dazu wem ist
Geschichte beginnt im Zweiten Weltkrieg
seine Mutter hat eine leidenschaftliche
Affäre während ihr Mann seid seine
Einberufung an der Front dient sie wird
mit Dieter schwanger sein leiblicher
Vater soll ein polnischer Zwangsarbeiter
gewesen sein als ihr Mann begreift dass
das Kind nicht von ihm ist gibt er den
kleinen Jungen in Bochum zur Adoption
frei Dieter wächst in Ottbergen bei
seinen Eltern Ferdinand und Wilhelmine
zur wehme auf Ottbergen ist ein
Stadtteil von Höxter im Weserbergland
also in der recht malerischen
Grenzregion von NRW und Niedersachsen
sein Adoptivvater ist laut
archiveinträgen oberzugführer also bei
der Reichsbahn wir finden ihn aber auch
als Bankangestellten vielleicht hat er
einfach im Laufe der Jahre den Job
gewechselt die Mutter ist Hausfrau als
zurwehme von einem Lehrer erfährt dass
er ein Adoptivkind ist da reißt er aus
er will seine leiblichen Eltern finden
natürlich wird er irgendwann aufgelesen
und muss zurück in den Akten heißt es
später der kleine Dieter sei in der
Folgezeit mit Zucker Brot und Peitsche
erzogen worden der Junge wird offenbar
schneller aggressiv seine Eltern fühlen
sich schließlich überfordert und
übergeben die da eine
Erziehungseinrichtung dort büchst er
regelmäßig aus und wird wieder und
wieder geschnappt als Jugendlicher
beweist er gern seinen Mut in zum
Beispiel auf fahren Bezüge aufspringt
wenn ich mir die Erziehung der 50er
Jahre vorstelle dazu überforderte Eltern
und dann den Begriff Zuckerbrot und
Peitsche furchtbar später wurde in dem
Prozessen ja auch deutlich dass es
regelmäßig Schläge gab für den kleinen
Dieter und Stubenarrest dass die Eltern
über streng waren da kann einfach nichts
Gutes bei rauskommen ja bei Dieter Zoo
weme trifft es leider zu im Alter von 12
lockte ein 15-jähriges Mädchen in einen
Wald stell dir mein Bein schlägt dem
Kind mit der Faust auf den Kopf und
fordert Geld noch im selben Jahr schlägt
er einer 20-Jährigen mit einem Holzstock
so lange auf den Kopf bis sie wehrlos
ist er nimmt dir das Fahrrad ab und
fährt damit von Ottbergen nach Hannover
mehr als 100 km mit gerade mal 17 kommt
er zum ersten Mal in U-Haft und wird
schließlich wegen Diebstahl und schweren
Raubes verurteilt
er hatte eine 20-jährige Büroangestellte
überfallen und beraubt auch eine
50-jährige überfield zur weme und
forderte Geld nach seiner Flucht aus
einer Jugendstrafanstalt versteckt er
sich monatelang in Erdhöhlen
Gartenlauben und Ferienhäusern später
bewirbt er sich im französischen Metz
bei der Fremdenlegion wird aber
abgelehnt und mit Blick auf all die
Delikte und Strafen in seinen Akten muss
man sagen er hat es nie so wirklich auf
eine Art gerade Bahn geschafft 1965
bedroht wirkt und vergewaltigt so wem er
in Niederbachem bei Bad Godesberg eine
Freundin mit einem Fleischermesser weil
sie ihn zuvor abgewiesen hatte
seinen Tiefpunkt erreicht er aber 1972
im November dieses Jahres tötet zur wem
über einem Raubüberfall auf ein
Immobilienbüro im
nordrhein-westfälischen Düren eine
Mitarbeiterin durch Stiche in den Hals
Marlon gigu von der Aachener Zeitung hat
diesen Tag später sehr gut protokolliert
an dem Tag an dem er seinen ersten Mord
begehen sollte stellt die dazu wie immer
morgens fest dass er dringend Geld
braucht er setzt sich in Würselen auf
sein Mofa fährt zum Bungalow seines
früheren Chefs klingelt und da die Frau
seine Chefs ihn kennt lässt sie ihn ins
Haus noch während er sie mit einem
Messer bedroht klingelt es erneut so wem
er fliegt ohne Beute und fährt mit
seinem Mofa zum wirteltorplatz in Düren
in dem Büro des Immobilienmaklers war ja
schon zwei Tage vorher gewesen und weiß
daher dass dessen Mitarbeiterin über
Mittag alleine im Büro ist
erst macht er mit ihr Smalltalk und geht
dann wieder später kehrt er zurück
bedroht sie mit dem Messer und fordert
Geld er nimmt ihr Portemonnaie und weil
sie so schreibt er sticht er sie
bevorzugen Ende Januar 1973 in der Eifel
verhaftet werden kann
vergewaltigt er am Aachener Raum noch
eine Frau und ein 15-jähriges Mädchen
bei einer Gerichtsverhandlung 1974 wird
zur weme zu einer lebenslangen Haft
verurteilt und tatsächlich scheint der
ewige Schurke zu wie eine kapiert zu
haben das ist so nicht weitergeht er
wird eine Art Musterschüler unter den
Häftlingen er erledigt nicht nur
Routineaufgaben im Vollzug sehr
ordentlich nee er lernt auch Französisch
und Latein er fängt an Sport zu machen
und nach und nach werden seine Auflagen
gelockert dabei ist seine vermeintliche
Besserung wohl nichts weiter als schöner
Schein denn später berichten mit
Häftlinge das zuwehme von einem auf den
anderen Moment aggressiv wird Frauen
soll er als [__] bezeichnet haben
davon weiß die Justiz aber nichts ab
1988 bekommt er regelmäßig Hafturlaub
wer bei diesem Wort an unseren
dauerausbrecher Frank Schmökel aus der
Folge der
untherapierbare denken muss der hat
leider nicht ganz unrecht zwar bestätigt
das Landgericht Kleve und 1993 dass die
Haft wegen besonderer Schwere der Schuld
fortdauert aber 1995 kommt zur vehme in
den offenen Vollzug bald darf er Joggen
mal in einer Wurstfabrik mal als
Hilfskoch aber seine verbalen Ausfälle
fallen auch Therapeuten auf weshalb die
Freigänger zwischendurch sogar gestoppt
werden überhaupt hält zur weme in diesem
Jahr die Justiz durch ständige Anträge
auf Haft Entlassung auf Trab oder wenn
es darum geht ob er vielleicht doch zu
aggressiv für Freigänger ist dabei tickt
der Mann offenbar die ganze Zeit wie
eine Zeitbombe und die Katastrophe
beginnt am 2 dezember 1998
Dieter zur Wimmer kehrt von seinem 166
Freigang nicht zurück in die Haftanstalt
Bielefeld Senne er hat offenbar schon
lange an die Flucht gedacht und was
leider auch zu den behördenfehlern
dieser Zeit gehört dass Dieter zur wehme
bei seinen früheren Freigängern einen
Reisepass beantragen konnte und ihn
sogar bekam absurd er flieht in die
Niederlande und bricht auf
Campingplätzen in Wohnwagen ein um darin
zu schlafen und um Essen und wird
Gegenstände an sich zu nehmen auf diese
Weise schlägt sich der Schwerverbrecher
bis zum Frühjahr 1999 durch dann klaut
er ein Fahrrad und macht sich auf den
Weg Richtung Deutschland so wie immer
radelt den Rhein entlang über Düsseldorf
Köln und Bonn bis nach Remagen wir haben
jetzt das Wochenende von Freitag dem 19
märz 1999 bis Sonntag den 21 März
aufs ganze Land bezogen keine richtig
aufregende Zeit der Bundestag hat gerade
die Ökosteuer beschlossen nachdem
Jugoslawienkrieg wird noch immer um eine
Friedenslösung gerungen die
Verhandlungen wurden gerade vertagt im
Bankenwesen wird gestreikt die
Gewerkschaften fördern 6,5% mehr Lohn
und Gehalt aber in der Villa in Remagen
geht es am nächsten Morgen um Leben und
Tod an diesem Samstagvormittag kommt der
Eigentümer der Villa um nach dem Rechten
auf der Baustelle zu sehen es handelt
sich um den 71-Jährigen kurz Schröder er
entdeckt so wie immer stellt ihn zur
Rede und droht mit der Polizei kurze
Hand zückt so wie immer ein Messer und
ersticht der Rentner der durchsucht den
Toten und nimmt sich das Portemonnaie
dann klingelt Schröders Handy so wem er
geht dran und hat Schröders Frau Maria
am Apparat er sagt ihr etwas Schlimmes
sei passiert er werde persönlich
vorbeikommen und es ihr erklären
und sie gibt ihm tatsächlich die Adresse
und wartet so wem radelt also in Remagen
zur 60-Jährigen Frau des Mannes den er
eben erstochen hat weil er dort noch
mehr Geld vermutet die Frau lässt ihn
rein so weme trifft dort aber auch
Marias Bruder Paul Becker 66 und des
59-jährige Frau Rita und wieder geht
alles ganz schnell Maria und die Bäcker
ist drohen mit der Polizei und so weme
sticht zu Maria Schröder und ihr Bruder
Paul sind sofort tot Rita Becker bleibt
blutend liegen er liegt aber später den
Verletzungen
in der Wohnung findet so weme weitere
8000 Mark er nimmt sich Beckers
Autoschlüssel und fährt mit dem Wagen
zum Bahnhof und lässt ihn dort stehen
aus dem entflohenen Freigänger ist ein
vierfachmörder geworden die Polizei
identifiziert ihn durch Fingerabdrücke
in der Villa von nun an sind
zehntausende Polizisten in Deutschland
angehalten nach Dieter zur wem zu sehen
Zeit ihn mal zu beschreiben zum
Zeitpunkt seiner Flucht ist die dazu wie
mehr 56 Jahre alt der Mann ist schlank
und braun gebrannt das graue Haar auf
der Halbglatze trägt er Doppel kurz zur
weme hat einen üppig grauen Schnurrbart
er hat schmale Augen die zusammen mit
den markanten Augenbrauen streng und
eindringlich wirken auf manche wirkt er
durchaus attraktiv
das soll am Ende noch eine Rolle spielen
so wie immer hält die Polizei wochenlang
zum Lachen seine Flucht führt ihn von
Bochum Remagen Lindau Dessau Rostock
Greifswald Frankfurt am Main Calw
Baden-Baden Freiburg im Breisgau bis
nach Cuxhaven später wird er im Großraum
Hannover gesehen in der gleichnamigen
Region und dem Kreis Schaumburg-Lippe
dieses Katz und Maus Spiel dauert 261
Tage aber als die gestohlenen 8000 Mark
aufgebraucht sind begeht der notorische
Verbrecher wieder Überfälle um sich über
Wasser zu halten und am 21 Juli 1999
vergewaltigt er ein 15-jähriges Mädchen
und besonders tragisch ist in dieser
Zeit ein Kapitel das den Namen Friedhelm
Beate trinkt
am 27 juni 1999 wird in der Sendung
Kripo live eine Fahndung nach Dieter zu
WEMA ausgestrahlt auf den Abbildungen
trägt der gesuchte Wanderstock und
Rucksack
eine Kellnerin in Thüringen meldet sich
und sagt der Mann sei Gast in dem Hotel
indem sie arbeite
er heiße Friedhelm Beate und sei gerade
in seinem Zimmer also Rücken sofort
Beamte aus allerdings fahren Sie los
ohne ein Foto von Dieter zorwehme
mitzunehmen Polizisten in Zivil machen
sich an der Hotelzimmertür des Mannes zu
schaffen der denkt wohl er werde
überfallen und drückt dagegen daraufhin
geben die Beamten zwei Schüsse ab und
töten dabei eben nichts wie angenommen
die dazu nehme sondern Friedhelm Beate
einen im Gebiet geschätzten Wanderer und
Radfahrer wirklich grotesk gesehen gibt
es auch als zuwehme im Kreis Schaumburg
in einem Maisfeld steckt ein Jäger hatte
ihn in der Umgebung gesehen und die
Polizei gerufen
die lässt sich aber Zeit und kommt erst
am nächsten Tag mit einem Großaufgebot
so weme ist er natürlich längst wieder
weg mal untersucht die Polizei liegen
gelassene Bockwürstchen und Pornohefte
man nimmt sie irrtümlich Männer fest die
wie zur Wilma aussehen das passiert z.B
in Fulda und in Dresden aber erst am 19
August 1999 nehmen zwei Polizisten die
dazu nehme in Greifswald fest ein
Autofahrer fährt dort viermal an einem
Fußgänger vorbei der aussieht wie der
Mann auf den Fahndungsplakaten dann als
er sich sicher ist ruft er die 110 als
Polizeibeamte dann eine sogenannte
Personen Überprüfung bei dem Mann
vornehmen sagt der
ich bin der den ihr sucht
vier Leute hat zur weme in dieser Zeit
1999 ermordet ein Mädchen vergewaltigt
und die Polizei hat irrtümlich ein
völlig unbeteiligten Wanderer erschossen
und das alles weil ein Mann Freigang
hatte der besser hinter Gittern
geblieben wäre und genau darüber wird
jetzt öffentlich gestritten ein
psychiatrischer Gutachter will die
Justiz schon drei Jahre zuvor also 1996
vor zu viel Lockerheit im Umgang mit
Dieter zur Wege gewarnt haben der habe
ihn während der Therapie in Bielefeld
gewarnt wenn ich draußen jemals wieder
in die Enge getrieben werde vergewaltige
ich eine Frau aber niemand habe auf ihn
den Therapeuten gehört 2000 wird die
dazu wem in Koblenz der Prozess gemacht
gegen vierfachen Mordes schweren Raubes
Vergewaltigung Nötigung und
Freiheitsberaubung verurteilt das
Landgericht ihn zu lebenslanger
Freiheitsstrafe und Sicherungsverwahrung
er ist in der JVA Bochum inhaftiert und
hier kommt ein letzter wirklich
verstörender Teil der Geschichte noch
während des Prozesses bekommt zur weme
unzählige Liebesbriefe in den Knast
darunter 15 Heiratsanträge das ist das
klingt vielleicht schräg aber das das
hört man ja immer mal wieder also
zuletzt auch zum Beispiel in der sehr
sehr bekannten Doku jeffreyama der auch
Menschen umgebracht und sogar gegessen
hat und selbst er hat für ein Post ins
Gefängnis bekommen aus den
Heiratsanträgen sucht sich der mehrfach
Mörder eine Frau aus Berlin-Spandau aus
laut dem pensionierten Kommissar starke
sagt zur weme die Kuh solle noch 20 Kilo
abnehmen dann würde er sie heiraten und
tatsächlich geben sich beide am 15
Februar 2001 in der JVA Bochum das
Jawort
sie sagt damals zu Bild es gebe an zur
wem auch wirklich gute Seiten die nur
keiner kenne
einige Jahre später stirbt die Frau zu
weme lebt jetzt als Witwer im Knast ja
hoffentlich bis ans Lebensende und trotz
all dieser Fehler die passiert sind die
absolut schrecklich sind da brauchen wir
gar nicht drüber diskutieren finde ich
dass unsere Rechtssystem richtig ist und
ich finde das gut dass hier jeder eine
zweite Chance verdient hat ja stimmt da
die Mehrheit der straffällig gewordenen
Person dankbar ist für diese Chance auf
Wiedereingliederung in die Gesellschaft
nur wenn bei der Einschätzung der
Risikobeurteilung Fehler gemacht werden
der dann können diese Fehler durchaus
tödliche Folgen haben ja und ich glaube
das ist ja ähnlich wie beim Fall
Schmökel oder der rosariese
das ist so ein Impuls zu sagen was für
unglaubliche Fehler wie konnte das nur
passieren also man haut da so direkt
volle Pulle drauf
allerdings sollten wir nicht vergessen
jeder macht Fehler das ist auch nicht
vermeidbar allerdings haben halt Fehler
im Umgang mit zum Beispiel Mördern oder
Vergewaltigern ein ganz anderes Ausmaß
die können potenziell Unschuldigen das
Leben kosten oder wenn sie es überleben
das Leben zerstören deshalb ist diese
Risikobeurteilung enorm wichtig ein
Garant ist die aber nie
und was in diesem Fall richtig gewaltig
schief gelaufen ist ist das der
Psychologe gewarnt hat aber nicht darauf
gehört wurde und so wäre so diesen
Ausgang bekommen hat sehr guter Hinweis
Toni und damit sind wir am Ende unserer
heutigen Episode angelangt wir danken
euch dass ihr wieder mit dabei wart eure
Toni und euer Mirko diesen Fall haben
wir vorbereitet mit dem Archiv von Axel
Springer sowie Artikeln aus der Aachener
Zeitung der Rheinischen Post und den
Schaumburger Nachrichten Aufnahme und
schnitt Toni Heyer Script Stefan
Netzeband Postproduktion weight watch
Studios München